[Music]
welcome back to off-the-record where we
talk about what we wish and take its
initial quick yeah oh you get the mug
okay I see I see I got the mug but you
gonna try to call me out for not having
to call you Adams Lee we all know I'm
not as into the boba as you guys are but
I still enjoy it from time to time
I don't like boba either it's just a
watching them I'm also mildly dieting
and I say mildly because this this my
forgot me a sick-ass banned me sandwich
this morning and I had to eat like
you're inspired by me oh you wanted to
you wanted a sandwich okay no you say
you ruined this guy yeah oh you only
hear positivity if we it's my favorite
sandwich of all time so when I
especially from from these two places
that he gets it from so I was like man
all right [ __ ] it cuz I said to you I
don't even ask you guys anymore I
already know what your order is I know
what you want so I get it oh that's
pretty nice
you don't even drink the coffee that I
got you well I had the Starbucks and
then now I have the Jun B and then this
thing is just better when it's melted so
it's [ __ ] messenger it looks
disgusting right now you know [ __ ]
good as new what I did I drink the
coffee he gave me and I said [ __ ] you
the Starbucks so I I miss I miss I miss
travelling like crazy right - but what
else I miss are the prices when I travel
sometimes like well I mean some
countries obviously - yeah but the
quality's amazing like the coffee in
Vietnam is no other like I was addicted
because we have one style it's kind of
similar right out there wait they have
more versions of this yes it's not just
cafe food that it is what is this for
the uninitiated okay so Vietnamese
coffee is basically a French style drip
coffee on top of condensed milk
yeah that's so strong but they have
other ones like they froth egg yolk in
one it's called eggs yeah and then
there's a strong raw egg yolk yeah and
it's like a coffee like imagine a root
beer float
right
it's not wrong it's froth if it's from
it's like imagine a root beer float just
a froth one tower of that a thick froth
of coffee that's all we used to make
chile rellenos hey guilt froth
ego yeah you whip it yeah you whip it
and then you you put the the chili
pepper in that and then you just fry it
and then that's the chittering it man
prove it make me a chili command you
[Laughter]
well dude these chicks okay oh yeah no
Mexican is my favorite usually tifus it
was time no no I won't we have a great
time spot next to us so it's it's great
but Mexican foods my favorite always has
been TIFF cannot [ __ ] cook Mexican
food pisses me off to no end
true you tease me all the time tease me
she's like I made this thing I made that
you know that you know what it tastes oh
that's the worst [ __ ] to say it's it's
so easy you made a lot of chicken and do
you know how to make that chili get ass
sure if you stared make sure my chicken
enchiladas good to see at that I can
make a lot of my oh give me some you
know it's really good if you guys ok
here's the thing man I know right now
we're not supposed to be traveling and
then like social saying shame and all
that right but check this out alright
there's a place that you guys always
wanted to go to flight is only one
dollar and you know one dollar lowest
case of the Rona's the very lowest ever
can I pay two dollars and get business
class I was gonna give you business
class for one dollar but now since you
said that imma charge it to your
horrible negotiator bar double the price
me dude oh you know we all have to pay
to the [ __ ] poor now are you happy I
didn't know that the class was being
thrown in there you just need to be
quiet and to take it for at all I want
to go into first class can I do that Oh
you gotta learn for me what its first
class $5 yeah I'll take it
oh [ __ ] I should have got higher where
are you going where are you going Juliet
I would go to Japan yeah but what if
what if what if what if what if what if
like are you afraid of everyone going
Julia how dare you do they set up at a
time like a [ __ ] she's not gonna
publicize it she's smart and she's
wearing a mask so she's less
recognizable she blends in with Japanese
people too
yeah but I'm just I'm just trying to
save up money right now though even
though it was fun but it's five dollars
I know but still because you want to buy
that dream house that you were showing
me you got a dream it's all you know I'm
like this
you still want a house though yeah I
still want a song I'm just trying why
you want a house it's owned property job
what kind of house doesn't matter I want
a house too
it could be like for like one story two
story I think it was asking if there's
gonna be a gingerbread or not no no not
I did your bread house but your
requirement you need to have a big nice
and big windows you like that yeah big
windows Arbor area a bar area you want
to live in our area answer the [ __ ]
question that has a secret room and a
secret tunnel this repo your suit you
shoulda be Batman
why not I can aspire to be anyone who I
wanted that Joe stop stomping on her
dream
oh wait question D I was just surprised
why not be that woman see I'm extra well
why are you trying to mansplain it to
her she didn't know that bad woman had a
cave in a tunnel why wouldn't that woman
have a cave oh yeah what the [ __ ] oh
that's whoa dude that's all well you
saying that women should be in a cave
and stuck there oh [ __ ] no no
because I think they should be flying
out free hey let's cut that Jeff let's
cut that I feel like that woman should
have a back kitchen right okay that's
being barely what's her name Ruby Amber
Rose Oh Ruby oh she just stepped down
those roses the ball brought unknown
reasons I'm dying this could be a movie
no it's a TV show
I wonder what's your take I know why she
didn't wanna be a CW star it's cheap
yeah it's like it's seen as lower on the
wrong not that I can say [ __ ] about it
in Hollywood it's seen as lesser and so
she she was in some pretty mainstream
films and so then all of a sudden she's
a CW star and that's just kind of lower
on the wrong it's like your careers
deteriorating a little bit on shows
mm-hmm not good I mean the ratings are
not good they're not friendly towards
that show so whose lady Joker Harley
Quinn is that lady Joker I guess so yeah
yeah pretty much
Oh cuz there's a girl version to it
every everyone right whatever Batman
Batgirl
no you said you said there's Batgirl is
different than that woman oh they all
exist in the same universe I just didn't
know that it existed really if I wasn't
here you guys wouldn't know but yes is
there a Batman multiverse do Batwoman
and Batgirl exist in the same world as
Robin and Batman yes really you think
they're Robin in Kate Kane is bat woman
okay
yeah I know an owner and I would have
never been able to do that girl is
Barbara Gordon but then she's also been
several other people to do you think in
Batman I mean Gotham City right now they
hate Batman for bringing Corona into the
city we wanted Batman have done that
well could they're blaming all the best
oh no that's the Chinese Batman dude
who's Wayne
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
so Ian over zone a message respond
Bruce Wayne man everybody knew it dude
Bruce Wayne I wouldn't goddamn cut for
the studio got damn oh there's a heavy
storm she's hot storms so hot I know I
wanted to be here and she was all like
but if you piss her off in the [ __ ] your
weather up yeah hello
piss me off I want to [ __ ] up your
weather no I like sunny days where would
you go for two dollars view for two
dollars I don't want it to be tropical
for sure I want it to be tropical what
was that I that's gonna go to Santorini
no I mean in Africa Galapagos no yes
more and more artists Murray Mobb Deep's
Madagascar no I hate you you never
listen to me
you oh there's islands in Africa yeah
where it's called like Mariah Marauder
small right I don't even operator with
ma RTI us
Martin March March March
no it's Marsh Marsh is work Marty I want
to know it's beautiful oh ma RTI us I'm
totally making this up Harley it's just
right Yeah right no that's a that's a
that's a first month of the ancien we
move on sorry look up African island
Mariah tiss Mauritius Mauritius if you
want to say it correctly I'll remember
that
right I have an iron from elementary
school named Maurice look at these
oh that looks like a lot of islands
though sure I wanna I won't go away what
do you mean but I thought that like I
couldn't pick one place no but like that
looks like a lot of other islands I was
gonna say like topical places if it
weren't for the locals like and the
reason why you even experience the
locals is from the airplane to the
resort but once you get to the resort
you're kinda like in your own like
little it kind of all feels the same all
feels the same can you tell the
difference it doesn't matter I don't
care
um I just don't want to be around a lot
of touristy places so this one nobody
none what do you do there like I don't
want to be around you tourists
sadly oh yeah
I don't mind being around tourists as
long as they're not Chinese no as long
as it's a tropical place I mind it when
they don't know how to act respectfully
or behave like haters oh sure I don't
like hearing either I was remember when
we're on the cruise and then we're at
the buffet and this can was like and
then the guy was like obviously he
couldn't speak English that well so
she's like talking to him as if he's
dumb and he's deaf and she yelled louder
and I was like I don't think he knows
English and then like it says on their
nametag do because there's an
international staff yeah they feel clean
Philippine yeah yeah absolutely like hi
I'm John from Indonesia
hi I'm you know whatever and then she
was walking back into the [ __ ] oh it
was so weird just that kind of [ __ ]
makes me uncomfortable dude it's at that
point that I started judging the [ __ ]
out of people though where I'm Lively so
I'm like oh cool your fat ass [ __ ] care
about gluten-free but you don't care
about eating a [ __ ] burrito for
breakfast lunch and dinner yeah that's
why I get mean I know right I see people
mistreating like especially waiters or
anybody like that I'm like man [ __ ] you
all [ __ ] destroy you yeah because in
my mind
they can't save anything back so it's
almost like you're picking on people
that you know won't do anything back to
you if I can't have you all I ever
become since we're talking about Batman
have y'all become like like a Batman of
your own ride against Karen's the evil
Karen's of the world I don't think I've
ever experienced anything Karen I hope
they have enough courage you don't have
enough courage Karen's are too much
witness [ __ ] like that though
Marquand where you going tropical $2
let's hear tropical I don't know if it
would be tropical I've always wanted to
go to Abu Dhabi though oh so I wanted to
check that out go visit some of those
areas I just tried to have your back
because you said tropical so I thought
well she she's married to you so you'd
go tropical but cool well she also knows
that she likes to go to Abu Dhabi too
right yep really a really nice
endorsement for Abu Dhabi
I wonder girls feel the same about going
to certain places that women are kind of
not safe we went to Morocco and yeah
there's moments where you're kind of
like damn it's not as fun in certain
instances focus on that part I'm focused
on there's a picture I saw the
underwater restaurant where you're
eating and there's a big-ass [ __ ]
whale just swimming by it that's pretty
[ __ ] cool yeah and just like as long
as you don't talk about your rights here
whatever you want to talk about and then
we'll be full off a nice lunch you had
asked ah Steve you had to [ __ ] fight
I can't believe you said [ __ ] Abu
Dhabi it's really close to Marusia
you're so [ __ ] jealous dude Mercker
she is really close today I'd go back to
the Bahamas with all of you guys for $12
alanis yep
[Music]